HIGHLIGHT TODAY.
LAME DUCK NEGLIGENCE FOR THAT'S
THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
LAST WEEK, THE PRESIDENT THREW
DOWN WITH DEMOCRAT LEADERS OVER
HIS SIGNATURE PROMISE TO BUILD A
WALL.
>> IF WE DON'T GET WHAT WE WANT,
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER, WHETHER
IT'S THROUGH YOU, THE MILITARY,
THROUGH ANYTHING YOU WANT TO
CALL, I WILL SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT.
I AM PROUD --
>> WE DISAGREE.
>> I AM PROUD TO SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT FOR BOARD SECURITY.
>> Laura: NATURAL OPEN BORDER
DEMOCRATS REPLACING YOU, DIGGING
IT AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
>> THE PRESIDENT MUST
UNDERSTAND, THAT ARE NOT VOTES
FOR THE WALL.
HE'S NOT GOING TO GET THE WALL
IN ANY FORM.
>> Laura: NO SHOCK THERE.
HE'S NOT THRILLED ABOUT IT.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE HOUSE G.O.P.
SURELY IN THEIR WANING DAYS OF
POWER, THEY HAVE THEIR
PRIORITIES STRAIGHT.
THEY WILL FINALLY SUPPORT THE
PRESIDENT'S AGENDA AND THE RULE
OF LAW, RIGHT?
>> LIKE "ELF," ONE MY FAVORITE
MOVIES.
I WATCH "IT'S A WONDERFUL LIFE."
IT'S I THINK I MAKE MY KIDS DO.
IT'S IN BLACK-AND-WHITE.
THEY ARE PRETTY CONFUSED ABOUT
THAT.
>> Laura: THEY AREN'T THE ONLY
ONES CONFUSED.
THE COLD, HARD FACTS OF THIS,
MANY REPUBLICANS HAVE NO DESIRE
AT ALL TO BUILD THE WALL.
THEY DON'T WANT TO FUND IT AND
THEY DON'T WANT IT.
OR ANYTHING ELSE THAT ACTUALLY
MATTERS TO THE VOTERS WHO
ELECTED THEM.
NOW, WHILE THEY ARE STILL BEING
PAID TO THE PEOPLE'S WORK,
THEY'VE MOVED ON TO MERRYMAKING,
FRIVOLITY, TALKING ABOUT OLD
FAMILY MOVIES AND FAMILY
FAVORITES.
THE ADMINISTRATION, HOWEVER, IS
DOING ITS BEST TO LIGHT A FIRE
UNDER CONGRESS.
>> WE ARE GOING TO DO WHATEVER
IS NECESSARY TO BUILD A BORDER
WALL, AT THAT STOP THIS ONGOING
CRISIS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> Laura: SO WHAT IF THEY ONLY
HAVE A FEW LEGISLATIVE DAYS LEFT
AND THE MAJORITY OF?
AS "THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTS,
THE REPUBLICANS ARE NOT FEELING
THE URGENCY AT ALL.
SICK AND TIRED OF WASHINGTON,
DON'T WANT TO SHOW UP ANYMORE TO
VOTE.
MANY LAWMAKERS RELEGATED TO
CUBICLES AS INCOMING MEMBERS
TAKE THEIR OFFICES, HAVE BEEN
SKIPPING VOTES IN THE WEEK SINCE
HOUSE REPUBLICANS WERE SWEPT
FROM POWER IN THE MIDTERM
ELECTION AND REPUBLICAN LEADERS
ARE UNSURE IF THEY WILL EVER
RETURN.
REALLY?
WE, AS TAXPAYERS, SHOULD BE
UNSURE EVER THEY ARE GOING TO
RECEIVE THEIR LAST PAYCHECK.
MAY BE A CHUNK OF THEIR FAT
PENSION, FOR THAT MATTER.
THIS IS A COMPLETE DERELICTION
OF DUTY, AND WE HAVE AN ONGOING
EMERGENCY AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THEY ARE WORRIED OF WORKING OUT
OF A CUBICLE?
LET'S NOT KID OURSELVES, MY
FRIENDS.
THE LEADERSHIP OF BOTH PARTIES,
AGAIN, NEVER WANTED TO FUND THE
WALL.
>> PAUL RYAN?
NICE PERSON.
BUT HE WAS ALWAYS AGAINST IT.
REMEMBER WHEN HE SAID BACK IN
OCTOBER?
>> WE INTEND ON HAVING A
FULL-FLEDGED DISCUSSION OF HOW
TO COMPLETE THIS MISSION OF
SECURING OUR BORDER.
WE WILL HAVE A BIG FIGHT ABOUT
THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO BE LOOKING AT --
WE'LL FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO IT IN
DECEMBER.
>> Laura: MY GOSH.
A FULL FLIGHT DISCUSSION?
A FIGHT?
WE'VE HAD NEITHER.
AS I PREDICTED IN OCTOBER, IT'S
ALL TALK, PUSH IT RIGHT BEFORE
CHRISTMAS, THEY'LL DO NOTHING.
DOES RYAN REALLY THINK WE ARE
ALL THAT STUPID?
WHAT'S THERE TO DISCUSS?
SECURE THE BORDER.
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT.
WE HAVE PEOPLE POURING ACROSS
OUR BORDER, CHILDREN DYING FROM
THE TRACK, BECAUSE ADULTS --
THEY KNOW THAT IF THEY HAVE A
CHILD WITH THEM THEY WILL BE
PROCESSED AND THEY'LL BE
RELEASED INTO THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S THE WAY IT WORKS.
THE TRUTH IS, REPUBLICAN
LEADERSHIP, FOR THE MOST PART,
WITH A FEW EXCEPTIONS AGAIN
NEVER WANTED A WALTER THEY JUST
WANT THE APPEARANCE OF BORDER
FORTIFICATION.
>> UNIQUE CAMERAS.
YOU NEED ELECTRONIC DEVICES.
YOU NEED THE AERIAL DEVICES.
YOU CAN'T BUILD A WALL OVER A
MOUNTAIN.
YOU NEED CAMERAS AND YOU NEED A
DRONE UP THERE.
>> DEEP THOUGHTS.
YOU CAN BUILD A WALL OVER A
MOUNTAIN.
OKAY.
ANYONE AT ANY TIME THEY START
TALKING ABOUT SENSORS AND
DRONES, THEY ARE CLOSER TO THE
SCHUMER POSITION THAN THE TRUMP
POSITION.
THIS IS WHY THAT I REPEATEDLY
URGED THE REPUBLICANS TO ELECT A
NEW SPEAKER BACK WHEN RYAN
ANNOUNCED HIS RETIREMENT.
THEY NEEDED A STRONG LEADER
WHO'D HELP AND THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S AGENDA, NOT SOMEONE
MORE FOCUSED ON HIS LONG GOODBY
GOODBYE.
>> I REMEMBER BEING AWESTRUCK
THE FIRST TIME I WALK DOWN THAT
CENTER ISLE.
THAT FEELING JUST NEVER GOES
AWAY.
I STILL FEEL IT WHEN I WALK ONTO
THE FLOOR EACH AND EVERY TIME.
SINCE BECOMING SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE, WHICH IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE USED TO IN
WISCONSIN.
I'M THE ONLY ONE WHO'S DONE
THAT.
I APPRECIATE THE INDULGENCE OF
THE PEOPLE I WORK FOR WHO
INDULGE THE FACT THAT I HAD
OTHER RESPONSE ABILITIES IN
ADDITION.
>> OKAY.
WELL.
THAT'S SWEET.
A NICE LITTLE FAREWELL ADDRESS.
BUT WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO INDULGE
ANYBODY WORKING FOR US.
PAUL RYAN IS A REAL KIND OF
PERSON AND HE'S A NICE MAN.
AND HE'S SMART.
AND HE CALLED THE TAXPAYER'S
-- SHOULD WE EXPECT OUR
EMPLOYEES TO WORK THROUGH THEIR
LAST DAY OF THE JOB.
IF THEY ARE IN CHARGE, WE SAY,
WERE, RIGHT!
ABSOLUTELY NO DIRECTION GIVEN BY
LEADERSHIP, YOU MIGHT WONDER HOW
THE RETIRING SPEAKER IS SPENDING
HIS TIME.
PREPARE TO PUT ON A PAIR OF
FUZZY JAMMIES AND WATCH
PAUL RYAN, THE SERIES.
>> A FEW DAYS AFTER HE WAS SWORN
INTO OFFICE, I NEEDED TO KNOW
WHAT IS IT YOU NEEDED TO DO.
THE FIRST THING WAS TAX REFORM.
>> OUR TAX SYSTEM IS PUNISHING
ALL THE QUALITIES THAT MAKE
AMERICA GREAT.
>> IT WAS POLITICAL SUICIDE.
>> GOOD WORK.
IT'S WHAT WAS NEEDED TO BE DONE.
>> I REMEMBER THE DIFFICULTY
PAUL WAS HAVING IN MAKING THAT
DECISION.
>> WE MAPPED OUT A CALENDAR AND
SAW VERY QUICKLY THAT YOU CAN'T
LOSE A WEEK.
WE ARE GOING TO RUN OUT OF TIME.
PUSH EVERYTHING BACK.
>> Laura: THAT'S GOOD.
FIRE UP THE POPCORN MAKER, KIDS.
COME SEE HOW PAUL RYAN DID IT.
I LOVE HOW THEY ARE WORRYING
ABOUT RUNNING OUT OF TIME IN
THAT LITTLE DOCUMENTARY.
WELL, WE ARE RUNNING OUT OF
TIME!
FOR AMERICA.
THIS IS MY LAST WEEK ON
TERRESTRIAL RADIO AND I'M
WATCHING A NEW PODCAST IN
JANUARY, YOU MAY HAVE HEARD
ABOUT IT.
MY LISTENERS HAD THIS TO SAY
ABOUT THE REPUBLICAN REFUSAL TO
DO WHAT'S RIGHT AT THE BORDER.
>> INCOMPETENT, MALICIOUSLY
INCOMPETENT.
>> POLITICAL OPPORTUNISTS.
>> INFANTILE.
>> PAUL, YOU CONGRESSMAN, PEOPLE
OUT THERE, CALL THEM, TELL THEM
NO MATTER WHAT, BACK OUR
PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: THOSE ARE THE NICE
THINGS THEY'VE SAID.
YOU MAY HAVE TO CALL THE
CONGRESSMAN, BECAUSE THE REPORTS
THAT REPUBLICANS ARE CONTINUING
RESOLUTION SCAM WHERE THEY FUND
THE GOVERNMENT UNTIL SEPTEMBER
WITH NO REAL MONEY FOR THE WALL.
THE PEOPLE IN THE WHITE HOUSE
CANNOT ALLOW THIS.
THEY SHOULD NOT STAND FOR THIS.
BRING ON THE SHUTDOWN.
FOR ALL THE BLUSTER AND THE
WORRY ABOUT A GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN, WE ALL SHOULD REALIZE
ONE THING.
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF TAX REFORM
WHICH, FRANKLY, QUITE A BIT A
LOT BETTER, AND VA REFORM, WHICH
WAS GOOD AND NEEDED, THE
GOVERNMENT HAS ESSENTIALLY BEEN
SHUT DOWN.
SHUT DOWN TO THE WILL OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR A TWO YEARS.
DOES THAT SOUND HARSH?
I'M TELLING YOU THE WAY IT IS.
NOT THE WAY YOU WANT IT TO BE.
THE REPUBLICANS WERE ELECTED TO
CONGRESS TO MOVE THE TRUMP
AGENDA.
IN MANY CASES, THEY HAVE
FRUSTRATED IT.
THAT IS A FACTOR THEY PASSED A
MASSIVE DEFENSE SPENDING BILL
WITHOUT ANY OFFSET AND CUTS --
SO MUCH FOR SPENDING CAPS.
SECURED NOTES ARE LIBERAL FORM,
THEY DID NOT AND MY CHAIN
MIGRATION, FAILED TO PRODUCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, THEY
BLOCKED THE PRESIDENT'S EFFORT
TO FULFILL HIS PROCESS.
THE REASON MANY OF THEM GOT TO
OFFICE IN THE FIRST PLACE?
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE BUILD
THE BORDER WALL.
REPUBLICANS ARE SPENDING TIME
AND POLITICAL CAPITAL ON
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM, WHICH I
GENERALLY SUPPORT.
THIS WAS NOT THE REASON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TURNED OUT TO
VOTE IN 2016.
IT'S ALSO NOT AN EMERGENCY.
WHEREAS THE DISASTER AT THE
BORDER REALLY IS.
SO WHETHER THEY ARE RETIRING OR
RETURNING IN THE NEW YEAR,
REPUBLICANS SHOULD STAY FOCUSED
AND IN SESSION THROUGH CHRISTMAS
IF NECESSARY TO GET THIS WALL
FUNDED.
I KNOW WHAT YOU ARE SAYING.
IT'LL NEVER HAPPEN, LAURA.
GUESS WHAT?
THIS IS OUR COUNTRY.
THIS IS WHAT THEY PROMISED TO
DO, IMPLICITLY, WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ELECTED.
BY THE WAY?
THIS GOES FOR THE WHITE HOUSE AS
WELL PAY FOR THE RETIREES, THE
HOLIDAYS ARE GOING TO BE HERE
SOON ENOUGH.
THEY WILL HAVE PLENTY OF TIME TO
JOIN PAUL RYAN.